November is just getting started and the
video games won't stop coming especially
if you're looking to catch them all or
build some crazy theme park rides here's
what you can look forward to this week
if it's fall in your part of the world
then it's the perfect time to take a
vacation to the sunny islands of a lolla
with Pokemon Sun and Moon the latest
entry in the monster collecting series
is putting more than a few spins on the
Pokemon formula with new forms of
Pokemon specific to the region and
powerful new Z moves the only question
is whether you'll choose owlette Lytton
or pop Leo your adventure begins on 3ds
on November eighteenth and if you can't
wait just a few more days then there's
always the special demo on the eshop
let's move from the sunny beaches of a
Lola to the CD urban jungle of San
Francisco the home turf of watchdogs to
this time around you'll take control of
new hero Marcus Holloway as he partners
up with the hacktivist group dead sec
your goal is to take down the evil tech
company bloom but to do that you'll need
to shoot drive parkour and of course
hack your way through the city streets
you can do this with friends and co-op
or take each other on in the game's
multiplayer modes like online invasion
and bounty hunter you can fight the good
fight on ps4 xbox one and pc on the
fifteenth we may not have a mainline
Assassin's Creed title this year but
that doesn't mean you can't experience
some of the best entries in the series
the SEO collection includes assassins
creed two Brotherhood and revelations
these are upgraded versions of the
previous games plus all the previously
released DLC so if you've never
experienced Ezio's story all the way
from Rome to Constantinople then this is
the best way to do it you can grab the
collection for your ps4 or xbox one on
the 17th what happens when the
developers behind a space combat game
return to their amusement park roots you
get planet coaster a sort of spiritual
successor to the roller coaster tycoon
series
that gives you an unprecedented level of
control and customization sure you can
plop down plenty of pre-made tracks and
shops but why not put your own
creativity on display by building the
most thrilling and puke inducing rides
you can think of you can start building
your dream park on PC on the seventeenth
and now let's make a hard left turn from
roller coasters and fun to zombies and
guns killing floor 2 kicks off just one
month after the events of the first game
and there are still plenty of zombies
better known as Ed's to kill you can
take on waves of monsters with up to six
players using everything from nail guns
two shovels or battle each other in the
new 12 player pvp mode you can expect
plenty more weapons creatures and
severed limbs when this shooter hits ps4
and PC on the 18th and those are the big
games will be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for tuning in
guys I'll see you next week